You didn't choose to watch this video.
Scientists can predict your decision 7
seconds before you know you've made
them. Your brain is running on autopilot
99% of the time. Almost half your day is
pure habit. Automatic programs you can't
control. You're basically a human
playlist on repeat. That personality you
think is yours. Half of it was decided
before you were born. The rest recorded
before you turned seven. Your phone.
They hired neuroscientists to make you
addicted. Every notification is a slot
machine and you can't stop pulling the
lever. But here's the thing. Once you
see these patterns, you can't unsee
them. And in that tiny moment of
awareness, something incredible happens.
Want to find the crack in the code where
real choice slips